there's officially been an update for
the real reason behind the mandatory
evacuation that took place during Mark
Norman's show at the New York comedy
club there were lots of possible Theory
shared online but apparently the
disturbance was part of a gorilla
marketing attempt for a new Amazon Prime
show about spies this same campaign also
disrupted two other shows that same
night and the new Show's lead actor
Donald Glover reposted multiple stories
related to the disturbance Mark Norman
said today that he had no prior
knowledge this was going to happen
however in the official message from New
York comedy Club they mentioned that
producers rented out their venue for the
night which seems insane that a club
would let this happen during a show and
not explain it until days later when
finally